today I'm here to talk to you about
DevOps versus sre this is a hot and
contentious topic which one's better
which one's worse are they the same
thing are they different competing
standards or friends for those of you
that don't know me my name is Seth I
work on the developer relations team at
Google I've been at Google about a year
and a half now prior to that I worked at
companies like hoshi carp and chef
software which are kind of regarded as
leaders in the DevOps space similar to
other tools like puppet or ansible or
salt and I've been involved in this
DevOps space for quite some time I've
written popular tools I've contributed a
popular projects and I've watched this
movement kind of from the beginning
really since about 2007 2008 and I'd
like to share my perspective today on
what I think DevOps is and how it
relates to sre or site reliability
engineering so with that let's go ahead
and get started in the beginning there
were two groups of people on the Left we
have developers developers are concerned
with agility they want to build features
build software and ship it as quickly as
possible to get it in the hands of
customers and users on the right hand
side we have operators operators are
concerned with stability it's not broken
please don't touch it and this wasn't
just a personality thing this was driven
by the business as an operator it was
your responsibility to make sure that
the system never went down and when the
system went down you got a phone call or
a page in the middle of the night and it
was your responsibility to fix it and if
you didn't do it in a timely manner you
might be fired but then in the flipside
the developers have all of these
roadmaps and agile and JIRA tickets that
they have to complete and if they don't
complete them and they don't get them
into production they're not delivering
value to the business
and the business is suffering and then
they're at risk of getting fired and
these are two competing ideas as we
introduce new features and new
functionality into a system we also
introduced in stability every new line
of code we write has the ability as the
potential to have a bug has the
potential to have a performance
regression so these are directly
competing ideas we have developers who
are trying to move quickly and introduce
instability and operators who are trying
to slow things down as much as possible
because it's not broken please don't
touch it but here's where things get a
little bit interesting developers work
closer to the business both physically
and metaphorically developers often sat
in the same building as the directors
and the vice presidents and the CEOs
they were physically located closer to
the business decision makers operators
on the other hand were often in a data
center their desk might be hundreds or
thousands even miles away from the
corporate office they often felt
disconnected they felt like their ideas
weren't being heard educationally these
two groups of people often came from
different backgrounds developers
traditionally had a software engineering
background computer science information
systems computer engineering something
along those lines from a two or
four-year degree or more operators
tended to come more from a practical
background they might have like an
associate's degree or a practicum and
something like network engineering so
there's a skills gap
on both sides developers are really good
at algorithms and writing software
operators are really good at
understanding network topologies and
failure scenarios and how redundant does
a SATA Drive actually need to be in
order to have this many nines of
availability but because developers were
closer to the business oftentimes they
would just write their code and they
would throw it over the wall to the
operators that animation was nice right
yeah I worked really hard on that
so these developers would throw their
code over to the operators they'd be
like here's my IP HP please go run it
for me
things have a great day and these
operators remember they they don't have
a traditional background and software
engineering they may have never worked
with these languages before in addition
to their responsibilities of keeping the
network up and running making sure hard
drives are not failing making sure that
servers are not faulting they now have
to understand bugs in the application
because when that application goes down
they're not paging the developer they're
getting paged they're getting woken up
in the middle of the night for a bug in
the application code but because
developers were closer to the business
when operators would complain no one
would listen
so the DevOps movement really in its
purest form is about breaking down that
wall between developers and operators I
know that was another nice animation by
breaking down the barriers between
developers and operators and aligning
the incentives between them we can
deliver software better and faster and
more safely for our end users what are
some ways that we can do this though
well one of the easiest ways that you
can break down the barriers between
developers and operators is to put them
in the same physical room this has been
shown to work successfully time and time
again it's a time-tested pattern instead
of having your operators go sit in the
data center hundreds of miles away put
them in the same room as the developers
make them attend stand-ups make the
developers listen to the operators and
all of a sudden you'll start to have
these amazing conversations where
developers will trying to be you know
they'll try to write some algorithm or
some distributed systems problem and
they'll have this great thing and it
works great in theory then you would
operator that steps in and says so
that's great but you're telling me that
you need 40 gigs a second for network
traffic and our data center is running
cat 5e cable which is maxed at like 10
over short distances and five in reality
so that thing that you're trying to do
like works great on paper and works
great on your local laptop but it will
never work in production unless we
upgrade the cabling in our data center
and just that small collaboration
saves the company millions or even
billions of dollars investing in a
software project that cannot be
successful because the underlying
hardware won't support it and this is
just one example of how putting
developers and operators physically in
the same space helps improve the
software delivery cycle if you look at
the DevOps manifesto there's kind of
five key categories that DevOps is
broken into the first is reducing
organizational silos and I've already
talked a little bit about this how do we
reduce the silos that exist between
developers the people writing code and
operators the people making sure that
code continues to run what we quickly
found though is that that was just the
biggest mountain after you reduced the
silos between developers and operators
who knows what the next giant mountain
is security legal review marketing PR
all of a sudden those little things
become the new mountains and this is
where the DevOps movement in its purest
form if you're a DevOps purist
you're like no it's just developers and
operators but in order to actually do
this successfully you'll see that it has
to involve cross-functional teams the
same way that we want to involved
operators and the development lifecycle
we also want to involve the security
team because if we involve the security
team early instead of our Security and
Privacy review taking six months for
someone who has no idea what our product
is was no understanding of our core
business goals we instead have someone
who's regularly attending our stand-ups
they're regularly contributing code in
or reviewing code and then when it comes
time to actually do the review they may
be able to complete it in weeks instead
of months ultimately delivering software
faster but also safer because they're
far less likely to miss something right
reviewing a hundred thousand lines of
code is much harder to spot a bug than
reviewing a thousand lines of code
versus a hundred versus one the second
piece of the DevOps manifesto is that we
have to accept failure as normal if you
recall earlier I talked about fire being
fired a lot
Clippers worried about being fired if
they don't ship features operators are
worried about being fired if they don't
deliver 100% availability this is not
okay this doesn't create a culture in
which people humans can thrive we have
to accept failure as normal any system
that humans build is inherently
unreliable and in fact I would challenge
anyone to find a system in nature that
is 100% reliable most systems fail given
large scale so given given that anecdote
or that lemma we have to accept failure
as normal it has to be built into the
core of our business right we can't just
fire people every time the system goes
down instead we need to plan for it in
in advance so as a concrete example
let's say we're doing a database
migration we're about to roll out a
database migration before we do that
let's plan for failure let's accept that
failure is going to happen so before we
actually roll out that database
migration we're gonna plan a rollback
we're gonna write a script that rolls
back our deployment and rolls back the
changes to the data model well why would
we invest that effort in advance it
might just work and you're right it may
totally work and that was wasted effort
but the problem is if it fails if that
deployment or that database migration
fails now your phones are ringing your
pagers were going off social media is
blaring your boss is yelling at you your
boss's boss is yelling at you the site
is down you're losing money and you're
trying to build a plan it's not the best
time to build a plan the best time to
build a plan is when there's not a lot
of pressure and you can think clearly
so by accepting failure is normal we
understand that bad things are going to
happen there's gonna be bad deploys
there's gonna be bad database migrations
how do we recover from them we need to
think about that before we deploy them
on a similar note the next kind of piece
of the DevOps movement is this idea of
implementing gradual change if you work
in a waterfall software development
methodology you may deploy once a year
twice per year
and the problem is if you're doing that
you're deploying hundreds or millions of
lines of code at one time and the chance
that there are no bugs in those million
lines of code is effectively zero it is
very very small but there are zero bugs
in a million lines of code I don't care
how good of a software engineer you are
how rigorous your discipline is there's
going to be a bug so you deploy the
software and some users start
complaining
well now you only have to search through
a million lines of code to find the bug
it's not that long it might take another
year versus deploying small incremental
changes if we deploy say ten or a
hundred lines of code at a time if all
of a sudden our monitoring starts
failing our users are yelling at us on
social media our boss is telling us that
something is broken or our internal
users are saying hey this is slow now we
know exactly where to look for the
problem the smaller that change the
easier it is for us to identify the
problem and the faster it is for us to
fix that bug or roll back the change
rolling back a million lines of code is
a lot harder than rolling back ten now
on the flip side and this was my soapbox
for a moment I don't like when people
measure measure DevOps success in
deploys per day
I think deploys per day is actually a
bad metric for success in this industry
you'll see it a lot or people are like
oh we deploy six thousand four hundred
28 times per day and I'm like great I
can add a comma to some Java six
thousand four hundred eighty six times
per day like that's not very exciting to
me but the frequency at which you deploy
relative to your business and relative
to your industry is a signal it does
tell you how how well you're practicing
these methodologies if once per week is
standard for your industry maybe you're
in something like FinTech or banking or
there's regulatory requirements and and
that's the industry standard that's fine
you don't have to catch up to some
startup that's deploying a hundred times
a day what's important is that you're
implementing gradual change with respect
to your business and your industry and
so bucks the next piece of the DevOps
movement is this idea of leveraging
tooling and automation and this is where
you'll often see people confuse
tools like chef puppet ansible salt
terraform as DevOps tools and that's
because those tools largely guided the
DevOps movement they largely supported
that DevOps movement and they coincided
with the DevOps movement so a lot of
people are like I'm a DevOps engineer
and I'm like what do you do now like I
write terraform configs like okay maybe
not the appropriate job title that's
fine but leverage tooling and automation
is a key piece of the DevOps movement
what we found is that after breaking
down those barriers and after accepting
failure is normal and implementing
gradual change it turns out there's just
a lot of work like creating users
installing packages building docker
containers monitoring logging alerting
like all of those things take time
and if you're a company that has a
hundred thousand VMs and you need to
roll out an open SSL patch you you can't
have people sit at a keyboard ssh into
them and run yum update it doesn't scale
and we quickly learned this right we
quickly learned that we have to have
tooling we have to have a dimension in
order to successfully implement DevOps
because otherwise you're just constantly
chasing your tail you're running around
putting out fires when instead we need
to be leveraging automation and tooling
to make things repeatable and to make a
pattern out of these another key point
is that humans are inherently very bad
at doing the same thing over and over
and over again we get bored we get
distracted it will look a butterfly
whereas computers are really good at
doing the same thing over and over and
over and over again so we should
leverage computers for doing the same
thing over and over and over again the
last piece of the DevOps movement is
that we have to measure everything it
doesn't matter if you do all of these
things if at the end of the day your
boss comes to you and says how much more
successful is the business and you say
people are happier that that's not a
business justification right and I'm not
saying that we should be justifying
everything we do with money or deploys
per day but we
have to have numbers to support the
efforts that were driving if today you
don't have any metrics and you implement
all of these DevOps things and all and
everyone feels better and you know what
the business is better but when your
manager comes to you and says hey we've
invested you know two million dollars
over the course of a year we hired a
bunch of people we bought these software
packages we invested in this tooling
what do you have to show for it and you
don't have a tangible metric to be able
to point to you it's unlikely that the
effort will continue and on the flip
side if you don't measure everything how
will you know if you're actually
successful you have to set clear metrics
for success and that includes at the
organizational level but also at the
application level now there's also a
difference between measuring everything
monitoring everything and alerting on
everything these are very different
things you may measure CPU usage memory
usage available disk space you may
monitor available disk space but you may
only alert if no one can use your
checkout page because if a disk is full
that sucks but hopefully you're running
in high availability mode and some other
service can take over and a human can
clean that up during normal business
hours all too often I see people
adopting DevOps and they jump right in
and they start alerting on every metric
and they don't understand why their
phone battery keeps dying CPU usage is
at 30% oh my god
30% why we need to measure an alert on
things that matter to our users is the
checkout page working can people
actually buy things from our e-commerce
site can our internal users run their
analytics and their reports that's what
matters that's what we alert on then we
measure the other things so that when we
get that alert we can find the root
cause or the root causes that triggered
that alert so what you'll notice here is
that these are all abstract ideas though
I know this is shocking you
no idea the slide was coming these are
all abstract ideas I gave you some
examples of how you might say reduce
organizational silos put people in the
same room I gave you some examples of
measuring versus monitoring versus
alerting but there are abstract ideas
right the way your company might accept
failure is normal it's very different
than the way another company might
accept failure is normal and what we
found is that a lot of companies don't
like abstract ideas they want more
concrete implementations so story time
independently of DevOps around the same
time though Google started this
discipline called sream which stands for
site reliability engineering it was an
engineering based discipline so kind of
on the the engineering ladder or the
engineering pay scale if you will of
people who build and maintain reliable
systems their job was to keep at the
time things like search and ads up and
running all of the time or as much of
the time as possible so sre is is kind
of like a very prescriptive way to do
DevOps and this is why you might hear us
say this phrase every so often which is
that class sre implements DevOps let me
explain what I mean by that so sre
evolved independently from DevOps it was
kind of Google was really in its own
little bubble at that time and they
arrived at Sree is the way to build and
maintain and run production systems at
scale and DevOps was kind of built by
the community and Google and SRT was
kind of built by Google at the time very
recently we've learned that SOE should
be shared with the world for quite some
time Google thought that SRA was like
our secret sauce if you will it was the
thing that differentiated us from our
competitors it was the thing that
differentiated us from other cloud
providers we shouldn't talk about it
it's a secret
we didn't even post job postings for it
but very quickly we learned that there's
a language to sream
there's nomenclature there's way
to think about production systems that
as a cloud provider when we go to a
customer and we start saying these words
we start talking about these concepts
they have no idea what we're talking
about so we go to a customer and we say
hey you know this service has three
nines of availability and you're
depending on it which means you can
never never have more than three nines
of availability and our customer is just
look at us like nines question mark like
the German Shepherd with the head tilted
sideways and this is when we decided
that essary doesn't have to be a secret
it doesn't have to be a secret sauce and
in fact other companies can practice SRE
and then Google stepped outside of its
bubble and realized that there's already
a practitioner based community in the
DevOps community that is trying to do
this they're doing it successfully in
some cases unsuccessfully in other cases
and that's because it's not prescriptive
DevOps is like an abstract class or an
interface in programming it says here
are the things you should do go figure
it out whereas sre is a concrete
implementation of that class it says
here's how you reduce organizational
silos here's how you accept failure as
normal here is how you measure
everything and this is why we say class
sre implements DevOps now just like in
programming you may have an abstract
class or in it an implementation of an
abstract class that has other methods
that are not in the interface right you
may have additional methods additional
functions that aren't in the interface
an SRE is the same way there are things
in the SRA discipline then aren't really
part of the DevOps interface but sre
does satisfy the DevOps interface and
let me show you how so if we go back to
the previous slide where we kind of
talked about the five key areas of
DevOps
how does sre reduce organizational silos
well the first way that we do this is we
share ownership with developers so s
Ari's at Google share ownership with the
developers by using the same shared set
of tooling across the organization so
there's a single set of tools that both
software engineers and us are easy use
for production systems
and by leveraging the same set of tools
you have software engineers contributing
you have site reliability engineers
contributing and you start to build high
performance a very reliable tooling that
helps people get their job done
on the other side of the organization
SOE has very prescriptive ways for which
we determine the availability of a
system and the way that we do that
results in almost forced conversation
and forced collaboration between product
teams developers site reliability
engineers and even sales and post sales
organizations
how does SOA accept failure as normal
well one of the ways in which we
encourage that collaboration I just
talked about is through these things
called SLO s service level objectives
which I'll talk about more in detail in
a bit but these service level objectives
in addition to kind of forcing
collaboration between these different
groups in the organization they also
force us to admit how reliable or how
unreliable our system can be and by
having that conversation we immediately
admit that our service is going to have
faults and as a developer and as a
product owner and as a site reliability
engineer I can determine how much fault
I actually want my product to have if
I'm building a product that is you know
up against some competition it needs to
hit the market very quickly I may accept
more risk so that I can deploy faster I
can deploy riskier changes etc if I'm
building a product that is targeting say
the healthcare space or the aviation
space like that needs more nines of
availability that has to work all of the
time we can't have hours and hours of
downtime we have to have redundancy and
availability and that may slow down our
development velocity but this is a
conversation that occurs between the
product owners the developers and the
site reliability engineers additionally
as you might expect the essary
discipline strongly encourages blameless
post-mortems which are popular among the
DevOps community as well when an outage
occurs it's nobody's fault and instead
we try to find ways in which we can
improve the system moving forward
something that sre does the DevOps
doesn't do is that
we then generate metadata about our post
mortems globally across the country our
country company so for example at Google
we know that like the vast majority of
our outage come from a bad configuration
change and that's a publicly shared
statistic and the reason we know that is
that in addition to doing an isolated
post mortem about an incident we then
categorize and catalog all of that
information into a database where we can
run reports and gain statistics about
what is causing these overall outages
and that can help you build kind of meta
tooling and and better improve the
system overall s or ease implement
gradual change by moving fast by moving
fast to reduce the cost of failure again
small iterative deployments are strongly
encouraged over a large you know hundred
thousand multi hundred thousand line
changes tolling an automation is really
a key piece of the SRA culture in fact I
sorry's have this thing called toil TOI
l I'll talk about it more in a little
bit but toil is this idea that you
should you should be spending on times
that bring long-term value to the system
so you should be investing your time and
investing your resources and things that
bring value to the system in the long
run SSH into a system and restarting a
service doesn't bring long-term value it
brings immediate term value but that's
something that we should fix in the long
term so sres
invest heavily in tooling and automation
in order to automate this year's java
way that's kind of an unofficial tagline
among a lot of us Ari's at Google is
that the manual tasks that I did this
year I shouldn't have to do again next
year
I should automate those away and lastly
we measure everything we measure systems
level metrics but we also measure things
like toil reliability and we'll talk
more about reliability in a bit but
hopefully this is clear as to why we say
class sre implements DevOps
sree is a very prescriptive very
concrete way to satisfy the DevOps
interface so given that let's jump into
a few key areas that I think are
important to discuss the first who's SL
is SL OHS and SLA is oh my an SOI is a
service level indicator something like
request latency or requests per second
or failures per request there a point in
time or an aggregate point in time of a
particular metric about a system
basically an SLI tells you at any given
moment yes or no for a metric in a
system is it healthy or is it not and
you define that right so for your system
healthy may be that the ratio of
successful requests to failed requests
is less than 1% right so 99% of your
requests are successful so at any point
in time if you imagine a point in time
that's a binary operation yes or no at
this moment in time are we up or down
per that metric then an SLO is a binding
target for a collection of those slis so
while an SLI is like a point in time if
you imagine for calculus if you were to
integrate all of those points over a
time period like a quarter or a half or
a year that's where you get your SLO
from so the SOI measures up or down and
then the SLO says how much up or down
can we have in a particular time period
again like a quarter or a half then
there's the one that you've probably
heard of before which is an SL a an SL a
is a service level agreement this is a
business agreement that happens between
a customer or a consumer and a service
provider the SLA is typically based on
the SL o ideally you want to break your
own internal SLO before you break an
external SLA because violating an SLA
typically means you have to give money
or credits or reparations in exchange
for violating that SLA
so SL eyes drive the SLO s because
remember the SLO is basically an
integral of the SL eyes over time and
then those s ellos inform those SL A's
but to give you a better understanding
of kind of who is involved in this
process
I built this handy slide so product s re
and software engineering work together
to build those SL is up or down then the
SR reason the product worked directly to
determine what that looks like
over a period of time and again this is
a function of how fast do we want to
move what are we up against in the
market how much risk are we willing to
accept what's our target market and then
SLA is are generally built by the sales
teams and the customers maybe with some
negotiations from product but they have
to be tighter or or less than the SLO
because again you want your SLO to break
before your SLA
breaks and sometimes s willies are also
used as part of a sales engagement right
where you can like buy more availability
so that's not really part of the s re
conversation other than the SLO informs
kind of the minimum baseline for the SLA
so I have to get this question which is
like okay so you you have this SLI thing
and then this SLO thing and then like
what happens when you like go over like
okay my system needs to be 99.99%
reliable that gives me like twelve and a
half minutes of downtime per quarter
what happens when I'm out like can I
just keep pushing do I fire my
developers like what happens next well
this is where error budgets come in so
one of the things that's important to
note is that it is nearly impossible to
find a system that is 100% reliable and
it is often cost prohibitive to build a
system that is 100% reliable especially
when you're relying on third-party
components take for example this two
dimensional material phone on the screen
this screen or this phone has 99%
reliable
with its cellular network carrier this
is actually pretty standard in most
countries
that's your SLA with your mobile carrier
provider so your mobile provider is
saying that we will serve as 99% of your
requests so 1% of your requests will
fail so let's say you have some back-end
service and you have an unlimited amount
of money and you say we want 100%
availability so in order to do that you
would have to run your own fiber
connections with redundancy to every
cell phone tower in the country of your
choosing in order to be able to deliver
maybe 100 percent of mail ability and
then you'd need your own kind of
Internet backbone to run that and you
would need on-call people pretty much
constantly even if you did all of that
and invested millions if not billions of
dollars the user would only experience
your app at 99 percent availability
because they are governed by the least
reliable components of their system so
even if you have 100% connectivity
between your data centers and the
cellular network towers that user that
end-user will only experience 99 percent
availability because they are governed
by the least reliable component in the
system and this is a key point is that
optimizing for 100% availability isn't
just difficult oftentimes it's
irresponsible it is not in your
company's best interest to optimize for
100% availability instead you should be
accepting failure as normal and
understanding how much failure is
available for your system so like I said
that user only experiences 99%
availability so how do you determine how
much risk your service can tolerate how
do I know how risky my service can be
well there are many factors to consider
like fault tolerance availability
competition in the market how fast
you're trying to deliver whether there's
a giant conference that you need to
launch at that was a joke but you're
acceptable risk dictates your SLO so if
you have a product that has really
critical market timing
and you know that you need to deliver
features quickly you may say hey we're
only gonna offer one nine ninety percent
availability because we need to be able
to move quickly and we don't want to
have to focus on reliability right now
we want to focus on shipping new product
and new features but again if you're in
a different industry like health care or
aviation where reliability is
super-important you may say like hey
look we only want to focus on
reliability right now we need to improve
our nines of availability so that our
customers can trust us so as long as
your SLO s are met you can continue
pushing new features and new product but
what happens if you violate that SLO
what happens if you've exceeded your
error budget which is the amount of
failure you can have within your SLO
well then everyone just like plays
ping-pong right that's how this works no
you can continue deploying your
developers can continue building
features but everything has to focus on
reliability they can't ship new features
until we improve the reliability so the
development efforts the focus shifts
from building new features and
delivering new features to improving
reliability and improving the
availability of the system until the
budget is replenished so just like a
bank account where you get a paycheck
and the money goes in and then you buy
some pokemon cards and then the money
goes out and and then you get more money
right the error budget works the same
way is that after we've exhausted our
bank account of error we can only focus
on reliability we can only deploy
features that focus on reliability or
bugs that improve reliability so what
does that actually look like
well here's kind of a prettied up
version of an internal graph so on the
top we have the health of the system
which is measuring the number of
requests that are under 300 milliseconds
at any point in time so this is like an
sli in the middle in the green we have
the compliance that up or down are the
note are the sum of the requests under
300 seconds so you'll notice that that's
more of a step function because it's
binary is yes or no you're either above
or below the line
then at the very bottom we have the
budget of non-compliant requests in our
SLO budget so how many requests are
remaining well you'll notice there is is
pretty far on the right hand side
there's a drastic increase in our
latency so you'll notice the little bit
confusing because the chart goes down
which is a decrease in the number of
requests under 300 milliseconds which is
an increase in the number of requests
over 300 milliseconds right so we see a
drastic increase in latency that
obviously causes our compliance to drop
significantly and then you can start to
see that just like my bank account all
of that starts to drop in our budget
right we start to see a massive drop
because we have a prolonged violation of
our SLO right and it's a steady decline
until we're back in compliance and then
we gradually gain a little bit more
error budget because time is moving on
and then we start declining again
because we have a regression and these
types of charts help inform how much
availability your system actually has
and then we're at the bottom of that
budget we have to focus on reliability
so you might ask yourself well what just
prevents developers from saying well
like I know I'm at the budget but like
this is an important feature why can't I
deploy it well they can but they might
lose their SOE support so remember that
sre is a discipline it's a separate
organization that partners with the
software and product teams and if the
product team and the software team are
not willing to be adequate partners the
sres will gladly hand you the pager and
walk away
at which point now developers are not
only responsible for building new
features they're also responsible for
the reliability of the system and I
guarantee you they'll start improving
the reliability of the system that night
at 2:00 a.m. another thing I want to
talk about because I get a lot of
questions about it is toil the fun word
toil
it's like foil but with a team toil is
best described as what it's not
those weird things toil is like not
email it's not expense reports it's not
meetings it's not traveling these are
all things we call overhead right things
that are required to do your job that
pretty much everyone in the organization
needs to accomplish toil is actually
something that is manual repetitive most
importantly it's devoid of long-term
value it's often incredibly tactical and
highly automated classic example of toil
is like SS aging into a system and
restarting a service because it's out of
memory or it's out of you know spiking
CPU usage or something crazy right
that's incredibly tactical like right
now doing that graphs go back down
everyone's happy but it is devoid of
long-term value because that service is
likely going to out of memory again and
you're gonna have to do it again and
it's gonna be repetitive and it's manual
but it is very easy to automate right
that's a classic example of something
that's very tightly
and in the SRA discipline we measure
toil and we talk about toil because it's
a very negative consequence of the job
if you're constantly working with toil
this can lead to like career stagnation
no one got promoted for restarting
servers right how many people got
promoted because they restarted a server
once right exactly
no one and at the same time a little bit
of toil is also good so there's a
careful balance here and every year we
kind of send out a survey to all of the
authorities at Google and most us our
ease aim somewhere between 10 to 20
percent of toil and their job so you
might ask yourself where's toil good it
sounds like this is terrible I should
automate everything well if once per
year you have to do some very complex
operation like some aggregate report
that spans multiple systems it's very
complex and it would take you 20 hours
to automate it but it just takes you 15
minutes to do it manually and you only
need to do it once per year it is not a
good return on investment for you to
spend time automating that instead you
should make sure that other people on
the team know how to do it so that
you're not one person documented etc but
you shouldn't waste more time
automating something then it takes to do
it over time it would take a hundred
years for you to reclaim that time no we
take you 125 years to reclaim that time
it's just not worth it
toil is also an excellent way for
newcomers like interns or people new to
the team to learn the system there's no
I mean there are better ways but one of
the best ways to learn a production
system is to explore it right and being
able to poke around and understand
systems and understand how they work
with one another
that's very toi Lee but it's also a
great learning opportunity for newcomers
to the team another value for toil is
that how many people have ever had a bad
day wow that's like you were also
positive people right okay how many
people have ever had it straight like 6
hour a meeting day I know that you've
all had that yeah right and then at the
end of 6 hours you have 475 unread
emails you've basically feel like you've
accomplished nothing for the day and
then you get a page they're like this
servers out of disk space and you can
fix it then you can go home for the day
and you feel like you've done something
with your life right toil can actually
satisfy that right toil provides that
instant gratification but in small doses
at a large grand scale we want to
eliminate toil as much as possible we
want sres to be focused on improving the
reliability of the system and the
availability of the system not
performing toilet asks unless absolutely
necessary so I've given you kind of a
brief overview you may ask yourself
where can I learn more there's this
happy link at google.com slash sre where
you can find all of this information and
a bunch more including two free books
that's free ebooks the first is the site
reliability engineering book I like to
call this the theoretical calculus book
and then there's the site reliability
workbook which is like the the problem
set if you will they're both excellent
books the sre book talks a little bit
more about the theory and the history
the workbook is a little bit more
practical a little bit more hands-on and
there's an entire section about how
DevOps and SOA relate to one another
both of these are free did I mention
that they're free and you can download
them for free if you would like a print
version you can purchase them from your
favorite book vendor so to kind of
conclude here is sre DevOps 2.0 no it's
not trying to be I also hate when people
put 2.0 on things is this are you trying
to overtake DevOps no Lowell and I
learned yesterday that I'm the only
person who pronounces Lowell I thought
people pronounced it mul can I adopt
both DevOps and sre yes as I said before
right if you implement DevOps if you
follow the essary workbook and and
that's our ebook you will be satisfying
the DevOps interface on the flip side if
you satisfy the DevOps interface you
might not be doing SRE
there are a number of other disciplines
like Victor ops has a thing called prod
ops and there are other disciplines that
satisfy the DevOps interface but are not
sre its DevOps dead I get this question
a lot like no one really talks about
DevOps anymore I think that's because
it's not dead it's just assumed now
right it's assumed that you're following
some or all of these principles as my
talk over yes we have about five minutes
for questions there are two microphones
in the middle of the room if anyone has
questions please line up at the
microphone for the recording while folks
are lining up if you have a question
that you don't feel comfortable asking
on the microphone or on the recording
that is my twitter handle feel free to
tweet at me at any time my direct
messages are also open so if you have a
question that you want to ask you don't
feel comfortable asking in public feel
free to send me a direct message I will
get back to you as soon as possible
thank you all so much
[Music]